While there's no one official
definition for DevOps,
there are several different descriptions
that practitioners have come up with.
One of them is that DevOps is
the practice of operations and
development engineers participating
together in the entire
service life cycle from design to
development and to production support.
Another definition coined by the folks
at Chef Defines Devops as a cultural and
professional movement, focused on how
we build and operate high velocity
organizations, born from
the experiences of its practitioners.
Now, we should be clear that
development roles here don't
just include people who's title is
developer or software engineer.
It's everybody who's involved in making
the software before it hits production,
like product managers and QA testers.
And operations roles likewise include
everyone who's involved in running and
maintaining production, systems
engineers, DBAs, network engineers,
security folks, and so on.
So, if DevOps is a practice,
how exactly do you do it?
Well the first practitioners
who started the movement,
also coined the acronym CAMS.
It stands for Culture, Automation,
Measurement and Sharing.
We'll talk more about
each of these components.
But first let's check in
on what DevOps is not.